what's up guys welcome to the third cci
tutorial video or commodity channel
index tutorial video within our Python
mathematics and Finance fan why I can't
say finance indicators tutorial series
where we left off we were actually
calculating CCI within Python and now
let's actually plot it into matplotlib
so I've got an empty script here our
calculation here if you don't have the
sample code links in the description
visit it you'll find yourself on this
beautiful page like this movie
Victoria's Secret anyway scroll down and
what we'll do is copy and paste this
code that's what I get for buying my
fiancèe victoria secret stuff anyway a
plot tutorial I'm just gonna paste it in
there so this is the sample code and
then I've left two empty spots basically
for us to copy and paste the code into
so what we're going to do is all the way
I'm just going to clear out some of that
space there copy and paste this entire
CCI function and the calling of it
obviously we wanted to take the moving
average part because we already did that
and the top part we don't need that
either so we'll come down here paste now
I got to do a couple indents here to fix
this nasty script here now to indents
now you're all set now we come down and
we fit this to screen right about here
also let me go ahead and configure idle
and make this text a bit bigger alright
so now we're we've defined CCI let's
pass a habit you know fill out some
variables for us so CCI x and c CI y
equals that function now we want to plot
up those things so the quickest way that
we could do this would be a student
apply CCI XE ciy and we want to plot it
as a white line done save plot whatever
plot you urge document or plot you want
to stock that up and here is our
cci for ExxonMobil and so as you can see
it's just a simple line here going up
and down nothing too fancy to see here
so one of the things that I did in some
of the examples I showed you is one you
can either add a zero line and then you
can also add the 100 line and then
negative 100 line so I'm gonna go ahead
and show how to do that now so just to
add that zero line it's pretty simple
it's just going to be a X 2.8 X H lines
or horizontal line and then you put in
the parameters where's the line what
color is that one simple enough so now
let's do another stock
let's do cube a plot up eBay and so now
you can see that we actually have the
zero line there so now the next thing is
maybe a 100 and a negative 100 so kind
of like how we did the RSI right with 70
and 30 and made it a green line I'm not
gonna do the fills if you want to know
more about the Phils check out the RSI
tutorial video in that other series for
charting stocks and Python so well do
the other horizontal lines because a
couple easy changes so just copy and
paste this paste paste and we can make
this the green this is the red the green
is at negative 100 the red would be out
of 104 this would be oversold and this
would be open bought and just for kicks
we should add our label so we'll say
plot while label and what is the why
label it's a CCI and what was our time
frame it was a 14 thanks for answering
and the color that we want to be will be
a white so we'll run it again we'll just
use eBay again and here is eBay and we
have our sexy lines awesome awesome
and sometimes it's good to have a the
grid show since I haven't actually shown
you guys how you connect them do the
grid and I think we've done it on any of
the tutorial videos in this section in
the charting stocks I didn't cover it
but you can do the grid by doing a x2
grid say true books true oh my goodness
this is a mess true color again why
that run it will use eBay again and here
it is with the grid so it's a little
easier to compare it to the to the price
now right so you compare the changes
basically so anyways that's going to
include the CCI tutorial video
miniseries in our Python mathematics and
finance indicators tutorial big massive
series so anyway hopefully you guys
enjoyed hopefully you learned something
new as always thanks for watching things
for all the supported subscriptions and
until next time